Transcriber: Reem Bsheer
المدقّق: gaith Takrity
مرحبا كيف حالكم ؟ عسى ان تكونوا بخير .
هل استغربتم؟ أنني أتكلم العربية؟
انا كورية أتيت الي الكويت
عندما كنت في الثالثة من عمري .
هل تعتقدون أنني تعلمت
العربية بدءاً بالأبجدية.
حاء خاء
أو عن طريق حفظ خمس كلمات كل يوم؟
شجرة، بيت، أمي، أبي.
معظم الناس وأنا منهم
يشعرون بالأمان مع التغيير
أو تطور الثابت.
لذلك فإن كلمة انتقال مفاجئ أو تغيير مفاجئ
لا توحي للفكر بأية صورة إيجابية .
لا يسعني هنا إلا أن أذكر
فيروس كورونا الذي أثر علينا جميعا
مؤخرا.
على الرغم من
أنه كان من المتوقع أن يتحسن الوضع
خلال أسابيع قليلة ، إلا أن هذا الفيروس
ما زال يسبب العديد من الصعوبات
للناس حول العالم.
بالنسبة لي ايضا كانت هناك تغييرات كثيرة .
في البداية شعرت بالرعب والخوف
من الخروج من المنزل .
اعتقدت انه لا يمكنني فعل أي
شيء سوى ان أبقى حذرة.
عندها قابلت السيدة العجوزة التي
تعيش في المنزل المجاور .
فسألتها كيف حالك ؟
فاجأبت أليست السماء زرقاء جدا اليوم؟
كورونا ليست مشكلة كبيرة.
ليست مشكلة كبيرة !
قلت في نفسي .
فأكملت. أثناء الحرب في الكويت
نظرت إلى السماء .
شعرت أنه يجب أن أسأل
السماء كيف يمكنها فعل ذلك؟
لكن السماء لم تكن مرئية.
فاختفت السماء.
هل تذكرين السجادة التي
في غرفة الجلوس عندي؟
كان عند تلك السيدة في غرفة الجلوس
سجادة ساحرة باللون الرماني .
كان يمكنها أن تثير إعجاب أي شخص.
عندما عدت للكويت،
وجدت سجادتي مغطاة بالرماد.
كانت سوداء تماما .
في كل مرة أنظر فيها إلى السجادة.
أشعر أن كل يوم معجزة.
خلال التغييرالطويل لهذا الكون
كان التشكل والانهيار يحدثان دائما معا.
فالانفجار الكوني الكبير
كان أعظم عملية انهيار.
ولكن في الواقع من دونه لم تكن لمرة
مرئية.
الأحداث المفاجئة كانت دائما
جزءا من عملية التطور .
قررت أن أفعل شيئا
لا أستطيع فعله إلا في
هذه اللحظة وهذه الظروف.
كنت أرغب في تحسين اللغة العربية .
لو لم تكن الكورونا ما كنت لأجد الوقت
والقدرة على تعلم هذه اللغة.
من وجهة النظر هذه يعتبر
الاضطراب حافزا
يخلق تأثيرا ايجابيا.
إنه معجزة أن أحكي قصتي بالعربية.
الآن أمامكم.
تأكدوا أن كل صعوبة
سواء كانت كبيرة أو صغيرة.
يوجد إنجاز مبهر بعدها.
ولتكن لديكم الشجاعة.
واصمدوا .
شكرا .
(تصفيق)